let me tell you why you're a brave man
I'm gonna give a couple examples why I
like you so much number one not only you
a great champion in the ring but out of
the ring you are a great champion
this gentleman that you're looking at
right now Robin was mowing his lawn he's
not a great Gardener no he was mowing
his own lawn and the man can certainly
afford to have somebody mow his lawn but
I think you do this for what physical
conditioning I just I just love it you
know I love the like that it's a
challenge you know right obviously
not all the time do you win this is a
challenge you lost I got my two on the
lawnmower so listen to this so Joe
accidentally ran over his own big toe
the big toe big toe with his concerto
now yeah and you cut it right off right
the whole toe hold on what was it a a
gas mower what was it you pull the
string in the thing yeah and you ran
over it and the coach
and were you like oh my God I'm so I
mean what the hell am I thinking and
then and were you wearing shoes boots
you were wearing boots
[Laughter]
you scream did you cry did you cry yeah
cry what kind of lawnmower was it I'm
curious I don't know what time it was
there's a steel tip boots you wear right
cut it right off wow boom and and you
your toe got cut off and you just
wrapped in the towel and you even poured
what alcohol on it
you know how that much Burns
and you saw the toe laying on the ground
and you said I don't even want it no
wait a minute the toe wasn't in the
ground the toe was on the booze hanging
off it was hanging off the boat hang it
off and you didn't pack it in ice no no
ice alcohol and when you saw the alcohol
then again
did you really did you put Ben Gay and I
drove to the hospital like probably 20
miles so listen to what this gentleman
is saying you got to admire the champ
he not only cut his own toe off but Dr
Frazier yeah he took his toe he left it
on the on the boot yeah he didn't even
care he didn't want him reattaching once
his gun is gone the pain was there but
therefore What I've Done uh I got some
alcohol did you really put Ben Gay also
well whatever I walk around with some
cocktail in my bag yeah right so
whatever was in the bag there you go
whatever's in the bag and then you
quickly I love everything in that bag
so then all of a sudden you you you put
the Bengay you put alcohol on there and
that's got to burn like hell you didn't
cry you didn't make any big deal about
it you got yourself in your own car and
droved
wow it was the big toe the foot you use
on the pedal no no it was your left foot
no right foot it was your right foot
right no my left foot your left foot
yeah yeah did you run lights when you
were running today would you stop at the
red lights and everything when you were
going to the hospital lights there was
no red lights all the expressway it was
Expressway
were you cursing when you when you took
your toe off or you didn't even care no
no problem can we see can we see what
your foot looks like
oh yeah come on come on I gotta see it
Champs
let me see what happened to the champ
whoa let me see it it's gone oh man oh
champ the whole damn toe is gone the
Champ's toe is gone
hey champ does that toe have feeling
anymore or I bet you the ends have
feeling right I never checked it really
that's it you don't even care I just put
there you go right so it's gone all
right that's it
I sit around worrying about the toe I
gotta walk
foreign